jusqu'à dimanche en principe tout bon
chrétien doit résister au chocolat ce
qui n'empêche pas d'aller observer
jusqu'aux antipodes la fabrication des
fameuses de pâques ils n'ont que quatre
ans et sont sur le point de découvrir le
mystère de pâques depuis une semaine
maîtresse alexandra leur parle de ce
monsieur qui aime tant le chocolat
qu'ils fabriquent toutes sortes duff de
jatte du moulage au démoulage aucune
étape de la fabrication ne sera oublié à
charge pour l'institutrice et vérifier
que la leçon est retenue étape critique
de la fabrication le collage
mais aujourd'hui les mains expertes sont
quelque peu fébrile l'impression de vous
passer un examen un examen la rigueur je
fais beaucoup plus relax
les enfants c'est pire qu'un examen
recette ne restent pas moins bonnes
comme en témoigne le jeune jury alors
c'est bon les 28 membres un sac
désormais qu'il n'ya pas que les poules
qui pondent des oeufs et sûrement pas
ceux de dimanche les et de bas
oui
là